Morning, Jaisal.
Morning, how are you doing?
Good morning!
Very good, one in green.
Are you doing?
I'm doing good.
Good. Hi, Giselle.
But.
Good morning, how are you all?
Oh, good, good.
In a busy week.
You have a bright, Sunny day there, Karine.
Yes, find a leash. Almost minus, not minus, but almost 28 today, they said.
We had strong winds a few minutes back and I was emailing Arkadi that his engineers are running late. It's because of untimely rain and strong winds.
Hoh.
Oh, well.
Mm.
50 kilometers, 50 kilometers per hour.
How about you, Giselle? The weather is good.
And today.
Yeah, so this is the time of monsoon on our side of the world. So this will go until the end of July. So it has started and it will go until the end of July.
Mm.
I hope you all are safe.
Ohh.
Yeah, thank you so much.
Alright, that's great. So, uh, how things are moving, Jason?
Um...
I haven't checked in just yet with the new two new resources. I had this session with them, orientation session with them, and handed them off and give them a plan. Well, Meet and Mike gave them a plan training-wise.
I will definitely check in with them tomorrow and get an update. Well, Sandy Pine was off. All right, right. So, Arkadi, Arkadi, I will check in with.
Yeah.
Tomorrow, and...
I think the others, I am going through invoicing, I think I mentioned to you already, I saw where we still have that issue happening with the time entries where it's not standard across the board.
Yep, regarding my mic.
It was regarding Ronan, the email that you sent where the ticket was setting in his queue for quite some time and post we got a reply from the end user and then it was uncovered. So yeah, so on that piece I have already given him.
the feedback and the corrections have been introduced already. So I'll make sure that this won't happen. There are a few things as well, which are underlying to this particular ticket, but most of the things are from Bronan's side, it is his accountability in the end that he should have.
reached out for help if he had any issues, which he did not. So that was the main piece where, you know, things fell and, you know, the ticket was not done properly. So yeah, that was it. And so we'll make sure that he will reach out in case he's stuck anywhere.
Yeah.
A couple others have done the same as well. As you mentioned, Arkadi had done that as well a couple of weeks ago. What I'm going to start doing is meeting with those tier ones as well one on one a bit more often and actually going through what they have on their plate because
from a tier 1 perspective, as I mentioned to you already, Ashish, I think they should be clearing everything on their plate every week. By the end of the weekend, on Fridays, they should be clear. It should be escalated or it should have been managed out from a communication standpoint with the customer that they
I read it, yes.
They are gonna close the ticket, et cetera, right? So, yeah, I think I think that's that's exactly what I I wanna see happening with that, so they can help move things along to suit, yeah.
Yep.
The.
Yep, I agreed. And second thing regarding the world growth election batching tickets. So when you emailed, I think it was on 1st of June regarding the ticket from May 7th, so earlier what I was doing is I was thinking that engineers do not have access
To get a collective view of the ticket of the world in the past, had to get to the results where what work role was selection on the on the type of tickets, so I had to spend some time with Ronan specifically, and I was eventually find was able to find the step where we could get the collective report of.
Right.
Sorry, yeah, yeah, sorry, I kind of walk back through with you as well, because you could query either time sheets or you could query time entries. And yeah, and then you could see your time entries basically and go through. And I did just a quick filter based on the name and naming convention that they use, even just keyword.
I, yeah.
Mm.
patching or patch and you kind of got that quickly. That's how I send you a little snapshot as well. So, but you're right that if they've submitted the time sheet, they would not be able to edit that after the fact. Only I could edit that after the fact.
Yep.
But yeah, I did a quick query to see what was what. Funny thing that happened is in between Monday and yesterday.
I noticed that Stephen ended up entering additional time entries for OS matching and those those entries those entries actually
Were.
were done for last week, as in in May, but they were entered this week. I got it, it was dealt with, but he even did it wrong, right? Which was...
Was it was it specific? Was it specific to his access or something that he he shouldn't do?
No.
Technically, he should have updated his time sheets Friday afternoon and then send it through. We shouldn't start to see time entries for last week and this week.
Hoh.
Is it did he did he submit those time sheets this way?
Right.
I don't know if he ended up submitting the time sheet. I could check it back, but I saw the time. So when the time entries are done and we're handling invoicing, we're going to see those as potentially billable.
I.
if they don't code it correctly. So that's how I saw those that just popped up after I had already gone through alphabetically that list. I saw someone's, some companies pop up and I'm like, okay, no, what's wrong here? And then I saw it. So I'll grab those time entries and send it to you so you can take a look at it. It's just a slight nuance.
Yes.
Kour.
creates more work for me, right, in the grand scheme of things. Yeah, but I'll reiterate it to the team too when I meet on them on Friday, but I know you'll do that too for me. Thanks.
I'll make sure that I'll take care of it.
Yes.
So much, Sameer.
Yeah.
Hey, good morning.
Good morning, how are you?
Finding.
Doing well, thank you.
That's great. Right. So just as we were discussing regarding the tickets and the option that I was earlier I was following is to collectively go through the time sheet and look for the keyword patch, as you already said. So what I did yesterday was rather going through.
Ryan.
Yeah.
the time management time sheet site. I rather went to the particular day, the tickets engineer worked on and collapsed the view and then selected the workload filter there. So from there I could go to all that individual tickets one by one, which would lessen the possibility of me leaving or oversighting a ticket.
Hmm.
Mmh.
that would have an incorrect role selection. And guess what? I found one ticket from Arkadi K that was from last week. So before you go and uncover it, I was able to uncover it for yourself. And this was the ticket.
Mhm.
Mm.
Thank you.
It was from last Friday, May 29th. Since the time sheet was submitted, obviously he cannot go back and make any changes to it. So this is just a small overhead for you.
Mhm.
Sure, I'll do that. Thanks.
Appreciate it.
And the new engineer, Ajay, I think he's training on Connect Price Management and the other university trainings that he's going through. When are we expecting him to start working on the tickets?
Mhm.
I want him to shadow some of the texts next week. So it's going to be probably not till the week after that that he's actually going to start looking at tickets. He will start as per usual on the alerts and chats before we put him onto the calls. Okay.
Okay.
Kip.
Got it.
Yeah, I think that's a good way to kind of introduce them and they have a bit of time to actually get familiar with the IT glue documentation and they're not fumbling on a call with a customer, you know, say, hold on, let me take a look at this and they're spending a lot more time keeping the customer on hold.
S.
scenario. So I think this is a better way for them to actually get introduced to the customer, the type of work, et cetera, and ask questions with their colleagues as they need to.
Got it. And just to give you one more update, that Sandeep and Ajay, they both have gone through the security training, I know, just to make sure that they are aligned as per the expectations. So we have made this process pretty clear that whosoever joins the MSPCOP team.
Kip.
needs to go through this training and I took care of that piece.
Thank you. I appreciate that.
Okay.
Any other suggestions or feedback?
Hey.
Not right now. I think we're making some progress. Actually, there are one or two people who I pinpointed and said that they didn't use the escalation template. You and I had that conversation as well too. I think that even if you're doing a warm handoff to the next tech,
Yep.
that they should be using that escalation template. So as far as those things are brought up to me, or if I go through and going through some of the tickets, random audits that I'm doing, then I'm going to escalate that to you as I've been doing by email as well. I will, I'll ping the text directly as well too. So if I'm telling you about it.
I've already had a conversation more than likely with that tech as well.
Yeah, I think that's a great idea. So I am reinforcing it from my side. The same message if it goes from your side as well, it will make a double impact and engineers will follow it. Although they are doing it, they have been cautioned on it already, but just to make sure that these are small things and if they tend to forget it, obviously the entire process deviates.
Ohh.
So that we just, which is we don't want to happen.
Yeah.
Yes.
Thank you so much. I will now go to Mayur.
Long time no see, Mayur. All things are moving.
Yeah.
Yes. Well, first of all, before I start anything, the thing that I owe to you, the feedbacks, just completed those. All months are completed. Anything pending, Ashish?
I received the CSAT service, yeah.
Let me just quickly check.
Yep, March and April have been covered, yes. So for the month of May, we will trigger the CX surveys, I think by Friday or by Monday. So I will message you on chat so that we are on top of it.
Perfect.
Okay.
Sounds good. Perfect. Yeah, so for the London team where I have the three techs, Ashish, not Ashish, sorry, keep forgetting names. Sorry about that. Harish. Yeah, even this morning when I responded, I guess.
Harish, Harish, and Akhilesh.
I mentioned Amit where you sent me emails, so yeah, it explains my day.
Yeah, I I saw and then I was a little game, it happens.
So yeah, that explains my day, how the day starts usually with me. So yeah, yeah, all three of them doing fine at the moment. It's just we are working to find a direction where they are most effective at the moment and where we need more help on wherever on.
I.
on a regular business hours, the on-site techs where they cannot focus on. I'm just trying to identify those areas, examples like alert management and patching. So that is one area. Calls is something we were focusing on for a while.
And they are assisting as much as they can at the moment, so that that is good on our side. Progress on Luware is a bit slow at the moment, with in a lot of vacations with the implementation team and all that, and so that is holding us back on on the data side on like...
Measuring the metrics on on who's answering how many calls and on that, so, but as soon as that is that gets done, we'll be in a better shape of, yeah, just measuring accountability on on the on that front, overall.
on my team for London and Gulf, while we're working on some...
KPI draft that again will be Jason and I will be discussing will be sent to international as standards. So once that is done, we'll share that as well. Just so we all are on the same KPIs, we all understand the roles, responsibilities we own and like on the tech levels as well. So.
Yep.
Okay.
Thank you.
Before I jump into the presentation deck, anything else that I should be aware of? May you, Jason?
No, I'm good, thanks.
Thank you. So I'll quickly share Engineering performance from the last two weeks.
Sorry, Mike, do you have anything to add? We we skipped Mike.
No, that's okay. I've got nothing to add at the moment.
In any conversation.
Okay.
Hey, sorry, Ashish, go ahead.
Nope, it's alright. Thank you.
Okay, I hope my screen is visible.
Yep.
So this is, these are the utilization numbers for the engineers until end of May.
So yeah, please let me know if you have any questions on these, on the data points here.
And.
You know the billable hours for...
Nitin, we do have, you know, tickets that he can be working on, as noted before, with those backup test restores, for example, more of the proactive stuff, so I know he starts earlier than the rest, and so he might have alerts that he's working on.
And that will take up a lot of time in the morning. If and if there aren't alerts, there are those backup restore tickets that he should be working on. So I don't want it to seem like if we don't have work for him to do to fill his time. Similarly with with Khattri as well on.
ticket closure, you know, on the tail end of the day. He as well, he started, he did start to tackle some of those already. He and I had one on one conversations about that as well too. And so, yeah, let's make sure that we are, you know, utilizing those resources on that day.
Productive in in that regard, OK.
Absolutely.
Are you anything from the site?
Yep, all good on that. And yeah, these KPIs we are using at the moment on the screen, yeah, those are a good moment, good metric at the moment which we are monitoring on our end as well, and so far it's good.
Thank you. Moving on to the next slide, this is in terms of performance observation, where utilization is getting better. Engineers are working on the tickets. Just as you have mentioned, I'll have a word with Nitin so that he can work on tickets from other segments as well to better his utilization numbers.
Mmh.
In terms of replacement, we have Sandhu and Khattri replacement in progress. So these are P ones and we are working with our TA team to source the resumes and the potential candidates. We have recently onboarded Sandeep as Sterling's replacement and Akshay as an additional resource from June 1st.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
We have made sure that email is available in terms of coverage and consistency with responsiveness. So this is taken care of. Ticket hygiene regarding the workload selection. This is one of the items that I make sure I check with the tickets related to the patching roles.
And engineers are also diligent in terms of selecting the correct workload there.
Yes.
Good.
Calls answered, so I make sure the moment a genius who start early, they are available in the queue because any call that would land up during that time, they are the only ones responsible to answer it. So I've been actively tracking it with a genius availability in the queue.
But honestly, since I don't have access to the tool, so I don't have visibility, the exact visibility. So just wanted to know from your perspective, Vishal, have you also noticed this behavior betterment that I have noticed or something else?
I, I, it's not just the IT by design team on this, but collectively the entire team. I tend to log in at different times and check to see who's in, who's supposed to be in and they're not in, and have a...
a quick conversation or ping them and nudge them and say, hey, you need to be in just this week as well. I know for sure Khattri K was one of those who I saw that he was not on the queue and I nudged him and he jumped in immediately. It is not an automatic thing, quote unquote, where when they sign in that they're going and putting themselves active.
And so that's still a problem.
Okay.
Yeah.
And out time, because you know I make sure that engineers are there in time and out time in Teams, and I also connect with them every day, reinforcing this thing every day, you know that you need to be in queue on time, but like you said, when they are done with a certain call and...
Going on entering their ticket notes, so at times they don't put themselves back into the queue. So, this is something that, you know, obviously I can work with the engineer from my end as per my resources and the things that I have at my end, but it could be an additional help.
if I can be given the access, you know, that would make the entire monitoring piece more smooth and less time consuming.
Agreed, agreed, but it's really, the onus is on us internally here and my team to look at that and because it's not just the active by design team that falls into that entire category. So we are actively doing it and then we ping in the team. I don't.
not due on that unless it's like habitual. But right now it is an overall thing that we have to do to keep reminding the team to jump on and be active, especially when they just sign in. And I typically see right before 8:00 CS.
Yes.
It.
In.
8 A.m. CSC is when I make another check to see who's in because that's the that 20 minute period of let's say 10 to 8 to 10 past 8 is where we've been missing calls and that's because the engineers are not.
Active on, they might they might have gone on a break, they might have forgotten to put themselves back active, and and so it's something that we're working towards is collectively everyone, OK?
Yeah, sure, and one more input that I want to give, I just got to recall it from the date when I used to work at an engineer, no, 15 years back, so this is something if you, I don't, I don't think if it is.
But.
If it's if it's valid there, but if engineers, you know, put themselves in the queue and out of queue, would it reset the counter? Would they not get the upcoming call, or this is not how it works in the current call queue system that you have?
It does look like that, where it now resets their idle time or in-state time. So if they just rejoin the queue, then they're the shortest in terms of idle time. So they will be last to get a call from that perspective because it's
Yes.
longest idle time that it'll go from.
It just came into my mind, so I thought of sharing with you. Maybe we can.
Hoh.
find a solution around it.
No, that that's that is how it it's designed. If they're code everything that code and code gaming the system, I that's hard to do because at time from time to time it'll be all of them are required, you know, so it'll be fine. I don't see that as an issue as yet, but
Yes.
Mhm.
Good that you pointed that out.
Thank you.
All right, next we have is coaching where timely updates of the tickets. This is something that I verified during my board reviews. And for the leaves, we have already shared the dates for the month of June. So we don't have any new planned leaves for June.
Any questions?
Yeah, yeah, I got the dates already from you on June. Yeah, that's correct.
Yep.
Yeah, on share my screen.
I see you've been joined by Lee as well. Yes.
Morning Lee.
Yeah.
Lee, how are you doing?
Coming on camera. I'm doing well, Jessel. How you been?
Not too bad, not too bad.
Good, good. Mayor, good to see you again. Mike. Mike, I don't know if we've seen one another before. I'm Lee. Have we met on this call?
Hey, Lee. No, I don't think we've met yet on this call.
OK, pleasure to meet you. I'm I work closely with Ash and Amit, I, except on the on the US side of house, heading up service delivery. So, yeah.
Pleasure to meet you.
Yeah.
Very cool.
Yeah, Karine, great to see you as always.
Yeah, no, thank you. I just jumped on to check in. I know that there's a number of things we're working through, so I just wanted to make sure I jumped in and overheard what I could and check in with Ashish and Amit afterwards to make sure that we've got things moving the way we need to.
Yes.
We do, we're in good hands. The team has been working, you know, to push things forward. We have new resources on board, but we're taken care of.
I love that. Thank you. That's great to hear.
All right, Amit, do you want to add?
No, I think good to hear that we're making progress. And Karine, I'll keep you informed. I know that I have some important piece of to-dos that is left with me. So we are screening a few people. To be really transparent, we spoke about five different engineers yesterday, and we were not satisfied ourselves.
Thank you.
Okay.
And at that point, we didn't want to send it across to either Mayur or Reza, because if we are not satisfied with ourselves, we know that what the expectation would be from Mayur and Reza. So we wanted to at least have the trust. So we have a couple of candidates lined up for today as well. All goes well.
Yes.
We will be sending out those resumes to you.
OK, thank you very much for your support.
No problem. Thank you.
Great. All right, so team, before we call it a meeting, just one final request. CSAT service would be triggered by the beginning of next week, so I would appreciate your feedback there. Once service are triggered, I will message you in Team chat so that we are on top of the CSAT service. So yeah.
Yeah.
Sure.
Awesome.
This is it. And thank you so much once again for your time and sharing the feedback. I will connect with you on 18th. So until then, please take care of yourself and have a great rest of the day.
Me too, likewise, and be safe with all those monsoons. Take care. Bye. Thanks, bye.
Thank you.
Thanks, everyone. Everybody have a great day. Cheers.
Okay, bye.
Thanks, everyone.
Thank you, bye bye.